so I'm really excited I am going to talk
about Gigi what oh and by the way for
those that are kind of strickler's on
design yes I do have a red background
and I know that's sort of a no-no but
it's after lunch so I had to figure out
a way to keep you guys awake okay so
we're going to talk about Gigi what
today specifically about Gigi plot and a
little bit about sort of the ecosystem
right cuz Gigi plot is has been around
for a long long time
alright before I do that kind of the
caveat you know my opinions are mine
alone I am affiliated with a lot of
organizations here locally my day job I
work for Microsoft I am a technical
solutions specialist for Azure data in
AI I work with the federal government so
I help the federal clients sort of
transition their workloads into the
cloud anythings relate to data science
analytics machine learning etc as Jared
said you know I am one of the founders
of data community DC for those that
don't know data committee DC was started
in 2012 with two made-up state of
science DC statistical programming DC
and now it's sort of grown to a
community of over 20,000 people in the
local area so that we always have events
if you go to data community DC org you
can look at the calendar see what's
going on I still run kind of the
statistical programming DC meetup not as
often as I used to but I still try to
kind of have a few events a year I also
teach I am an adjunct professor at
Georgetown and a GW I teach a big data
class and this semester I'm actually
taken to teaching a date of is class so
it's kind of the talk today sort of
spawned from from that so you might ask
yourself well what do I do when I'm not
teaching working or running a meet-up
that's my family
my daughter Samantha my son Joseph and
Karen who's in the back hi Karen she's
really embarrassed so a little anecdote
about my daughter Samantha um I went to
the our ladies meet up last week with
Kelly and I got home and you know she
knows I've run all these things and when
I got home she asked me like what are
you doing I said I was at this meetup is
with our ladies and her eyes just like
went like this big she's 13 she's like
and you know she's not about art but
when I told like obsessively about our
ladies she just went like that and she's
like I want to go to the next event so I
will bring my 13 year old daughter to
the next Our Lady's event whenever that
happens so I'm excited we might have a
potential or user here I'm really
excited
okay ggplot so raise your hand if you
know and/or use GGY
okay yeah that's what I figured
so how many people got started in our
because of ggplot okay so a lesser but
that's actually kind of my I mean a
little bit of my about my story the
first few things I did when I started
learning art which by the way I started
running the meetup group without knowing
our I was really interested in the
community
I had gone to New York a couple of times
before Jarrod's time just clarify that
and I'd seen what they were doing over
there and I'm like you know enmity what
is it imitation is the best form of
flattery so I figured let's just do the
same thing and I volunteered to kind of
start running the group a few years ago
and I didn't know and the first few
meetings we just sort of sat a small
group of people ten people and our
speakers were just talk and we would
just listen for three hours sort of
everyone was in the room odd about what
was going on so that was the start but
anyway going back to ggplot the first
things that I started doing a lot with
our was of course visualizations and
this was probably about 2010 so this is
before ggplot even 1.0 was probably
still 0.9 so the ggplot you know today
is very very very different than the
ggplot of yesteryear right it is there
was an article a few months ago or last
year about the tenth birthday of ggplot
and it's at version 3.0 so you know
before if you want
and you know this is actually I found
this today this is a little gist that I
wrote on my just my github account years
ago I needed to do a hex pin plot ggplot
didn't have a hex pin plot so I used the
hex Ben funk did a hex bin package and
the HTM is packaged to do all the
cutting and basically extracted the data
from this object and threw it into
ggplot for the actual plotting part
because the jeep L didn't do hex bin but
now it actually does but the point is
how many packages so there are about I
don't know 13,000 packages on cran today
roughly how many packages do you think
that ggplot either like either like
packages that depend on or and/or import
these are two different words but
essentially that for lack of a better
explanation packages that actually
depend on ggplot throw a number out
there
how many 5000 now it's too big but good
guess anybody care to guess you're not
the next contestant The Price is Right
I'm sorry alright so the number is 1400
I mean think about it right like and
these are things that you probably don't
even know about neither do i because
it's so big but that's kind of the point
that's sort of what I wanted to I wanted
to show you a little bit of but what
about the things that are out there now
you know focusing more on the the more
current packages or things that are
really ingrained into ggplot right
because the ggplot ecosystem has evolved
so much it's a great tool I keep using
it not on a day-by-day basis but you
know I still love building a graph kind
of thinking from data building a graph
and sort of coding it and making it look
beautiful so alright so I know sorry the
text is a little small but here's a plot
these are so this is a facet of plot you
know that so first of all this is a plot
that shows the essentially the number
the on the x-axis you have the number of
cran downloads for a given package over
the last five years I figured there's no
real way to know understand kind of the
extent of a package but as a proxy for
that
I used a package called cran I forget to
pull the statistics from cran and you
know which tells it like all the
different packages
what depends on watch so you can you can
surely build a graph along all those
dependencies not not from a like DevOps
perspective and you know max can talk
about that because max builds ggplot
every time there's a release and I hear
it takes like 12 hours so but more for
like understanding now here's the thing
I actually I actually the color blue so
the color red means just the package the
blue color means a current ggplot
extension ggplot has a whole slew of
extensions going for it today about 40
if I'm not mistaken and these are really
think of them as add-ons things that
allow you to do other things that you
can't really do with ggplot unless you
you know you could decode it but these
are just mechanisms of extending ggplot
with adding new statistics new genomes
new geometric objects new other and a
new layer sorry new layering
capabilities etc but what's really
interesting right again so we see you
know what's interesting is like the top
the top packages over here so there's
the pens and imports I'm not really sure
that what the difference means so anyone
that's more versed in the package
ecosystem to talk about that but it's
just the way you know some packages
depend on package some package import
import usually means that actually loads
another package into your namespace as
you as you load in your package so but
we see at the top this is the depends so
we have H miss that's Frank Carroll's
kind of historical our package like
utility package it depends it it's a
ggplot I didn't know that carrot now
some of the blue ones are current
extensions so we've got I'll just read
them from my screen if I can but there
are like Gigi something it's just well
sorry I can't read it but the point is
you know what's interesting is you start
seeing kind of the the now granted this
is over this is just a total of our five
year period some of these extensions are
newer so the numbers are definitely you
know when it won't aren't supposed to be
that high but they're actually pretty
high if you look about it now what does
that mean that means that people
actually know about these I thought
people would not necessarily know about
these extensions or other packages
but there's a really long tail of all
these packages that depend on ggplot
that again I have no idea what they are
and probably neither do you unless you
were doing something really really
specific or you wrote a package and you
upload it at the cran a few years ago
because you were doing something really
really specific
there's just no I guess there's no other
than like some of the you know like the
art studio site and and the website that
I'm going to show you in a second
there's there's really no good mechanism
of understanding the extent of it but I
wanted to show you that there is a huge
impact right there is a huge extent of
what just like how ggplot is being used
so much so actually this is the code so
actually to build this plot I used one
of the extensions it's called GG stance
and this is just the code and
essentially what GG stance does is it
make it converts it takes your standard
geo makes them like flips them
horizontally rather than like building a
plot normally and doing coordinate flip
you build it from kind of you just sort
of switch your your variables around and
it builds your genomes in a horizontal
fashion so if we go back to the plot
that's you know it's a horizontal bar
chart but I defined the X as X and the Y
as Y and I didn't have to flip anything
I wanted to try a new one another
another of the the current extensions
called GG repeal Gigi repeal which
allows you to take text it actually I'll
show you a picture about it but it
doesn't the it doesn't the genome sorry
the genome bar H genome doesn't take a
label as an aesthetic so I couldn't use
it wasn't working that well so what are
these extensions these extensions are
called ggplot extensions there's a great
website called ggplot2 XTS org a
beautiful website and if you go to it
it's over here and again there's all of
the ones that are published I don't know
if they're more there may be more I'm
not sure but at least these are
published on the website you can
actually add your extension if you build
one so this is this is a good resource
right if you've never heard of these
extensions like at least you know where
to go find them and a lot of these
incorporate you know some of the newer
dynamic plotting stuff you know it's not
just static it's it's for rendering
stuff on shine
or for web applications or whatever more
what I'm focusing on today is more on
the static stuff so so now you know not
so I'm gonna just you know I'm going to
talk a little bit about kind of the ones
that I kind of like the most so there's
40 of them I'm just gonna go through the
screenshots but the first one is Gigi I
RAF and what this does is just allows
you to make Gigi plots interactive you
know you know sometimes you don't have
to build a shiny app or do something
really complex you just need to make a
just a simple graph interactive so that
allows you to do that this is Gigi
rappel so actually I have the the
website open here so the whole idea of
Gigi rappel is like oh are you oh sorry
let me exit presentation mode
so the whole idea of GM tech of GG
repeal is that if you pass in a genome
with labels or something it will
actually re relay out the text part of
it so that actually looks legible
because otherwise it's right like your
labels on top of your data point so
pretty good I mean sometimes you need to
plus stuff and your text is just and
again I loved I really loved ggplot and
you know a lot of times that the first
colleague the ggplot in the genome gets
you probably 80% of the 80% of the way
there but then to get it to really
really look nice and to look you know
picture-perfect publishing ready I mean
there's all these options you can tweak
it's so extensible but learning all the
possibilities is just overwhelming
sometimes so but anyway I still I still
love it though let's see what else the
next one is this one is called G graph
so G graph who here makes graphs for a
living okay so if you haven't tried
Geograph I really recommend if you use I
graph G graph is actually a wrapper on
top of I graph and it makes you know it
uses the uses the ggplot syntax it uses
sort of kind of the tidy verse
mechanisms and the ggplot syntax to
really build a graph so I'm gonna show
you quickly what that might look like so
okay so that this one here I guess I'm
jumping the gun here but so this is this
is actually a plot made with G graph and
what you do is you build you there you
use that in combination with a package
called tidy graph which basically allows
you to make a graph object from tables
and data frames and then you pass that
into G graph and you tell it to plot
your nodes plot your edges and it uses
the same type of syntax the S that
extend tax and this and that so you know
I graph is great but the plotting part
of I graph is so raise your hand if you
agree with that okay there we go
so try Gertz write a try G graph let's
see what else
there's another one called GM net I
haven't used that one but it's also
another another another another plotting
package let's see her
now this one is called GG themes it's uh
it sort of packages together a bunch of
pre-made themes I think there is like an
Airbnb theme and there's a whole bunch
of themes that people have created for
you know making like you know like at
the Economist theme or things like that
if you want to use make your plot look
like you're not in standard GG plot
thing again there's 40 of these so I'm
not gonna talk about it but I did want
to make you aware and that's really the
purpose of today I just wanted to share
all this information with you in case
you didn't know about it and show you is
like a couple of things how easy this
can make it another one these are more
so there's Gigi mosaic and these other
ones and then what they lost to the the
the one the last one I'm going to show
today is this one called Gigi ridges
which I really like and to do that I was
going to go and use well I guess first
of all who likes Lego so we see a Lego
theme right Rafi and I you know I didn't
know you were talking about Lego either
or oligo as a theme but so I again it in
order to demo some of these things I
wanted to build a couple of visits and I
got the data from a website called
Reaper cable if you don't know about
this it's really cool it's actually a
website kind of a user kind of a Lego
enthusiasts maintained website there's
another one called lug net I believe but
what dig do they actually have all this
database of all of the different Lego
sets that have been created over time
with an inventory of parts what colors
they have the themes whatnot and they
actually provide all the data in CSV
formats and this is sort of the cause
this is kind of I guess not in a
database format but these this is the
link the data diagram or the data
dictionary between all the sets so you
know you can see what what theme a set
is what year it is and so there's
actually like a lot of really creative
stuff that you can do and I was hoping I
mean I want I started playing around
with some of these extensions to do some
visualizations I was successful in some
and not so successful in others so the
first one is at least I wanted to show
you right through the purposes of GG
readers so this is just a plot somebody
else made this this is a plot of the
average number of Lego parts over over
time kind of
just taking all the sets per year taking
the average and counting the number of
parts so you see that on average it
looks like the sets have been getting
bigger there seems to be some of it
somewhat of a dip I'm not looking to
explain that I'm anyway so it's like a
nice looking plot probably could be
better so that's kind of the data that
we're working with you know the table of
the years and things like that and so I
kind of wanted to extend that a little
bit and
so I always tell people not to live code
and then I always end up life coding so
so here's my data frame so again the
next thing is I just wanted to look at a
distribute like I didn't want to look at
the average I wanted to look at a
distribution so what I do I just do a
box plot that's kind of ugly it is sort
of a mean you do have some form of a
power distribution you have a you know a
lot of sets with a small number of parts
and all very little number with a big
number of parts so that's what you have
all this stuff and all these outliers so
again this is just using basic ggplot
but I wanted to show you the GG ridges
because I thought that that might lend
itself to to do something that looked a
little bit interesting because I really
like this at least the way they show it
over here and the website I like well
now let me go back here to the
extensions
I really like this you know what I was
hoping to do it's well sorry it's all
the way down here
something like this basically like kind
of you know it gives you kind of plot
the difference you know you have maybe
you're the y-axis being time so just so
kind of see that how that distribution
changes over time with some color with
with GG ridges the nice thing about GG
ridges is that I this is this is a
personal opinion but I like these
because unlike box plots or violin plot
so box plots just gives you a square
right and violin plots takes the
distribution but makes it you know it
opens it up and you have two sides to it
a lot of times that makes the data look
inflated I believe you know just
visually I think a violin plot it
probably has its use cases it personally
I believe that I think of violin plot
should spare be used sparingly so I I
kind of like this because it allows you
to plot all these different
distributions over whatever however
you're going to partition your data so I
I attempted to do that it wasn't very
successful but I'll show you at least
you know so I'm using the so I'm loading
in the library I'm using GG ridges and
I'm just loading this in and it looks
like one big ugly mess so yeah I I still
don't know how to get it to like overlay
but you kind of sort of see you see a
bit different I don't know if I'm
plotting the right thing either again
it's kind of the nice thing it's true
because I'm I'm calculating rather I
think I'm calculating the different kind
of distribution again read the docs so
yeah read the docs uh so to wrap up I
will go back to this and again this was
a little plot that I made with the G
graph
and here's the plot here's the code for
the plot what I was hoping to do is to
do something like this with the colors
of the Lego the evolution of colors over
time of Lego so does anybody recognize
this so I'm sorry
yes so this is the evolution of Crayola
colors over whatever 70 years this was I
don't remember who did it originally but
actually someone this is not I don't
believe this is a ggplot version but
then someone went and took and made it
like a ggplot version of this so I
wanted to see if I could use the
extensions some of the extensions to
kind of make you know take because the
colors of Lego has changed and the nice
thing about the data set is actually
rich enough that it tells you the colors
of the pieces with RGB values and all
the sort of stuff so again I'm kind of a
lego not I'm kind of was playing around
with this and I thought that was an
interesting data set to use so that's
what I wanted to do haven't achieved
that but I'll get there
no packages were harmed in the making of
this talk I these are some of the other
packages that I use that are not tidy
verse or ggplot so I use rep ryx thanks
Mauro for telling me about that last
night so this code is actually cut and
pasted from from art in our session and
I could just paste it into PowerPoint
and it looks great so thank you about
that cran logs and DL stats are where I
got the data for the packages like the
package metadata so thank you all for
being here it's a really a pleasure to
have you come to our meetup events join
us be a part of the community enjoy the
rest of the conference hang out have fun
talk to people and thanks it once again
[Applause]